hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar approaches to nucleic acid
isolation from sample to ngs analysis
presented by dr stephanie stepanov ngs
core facility manager
private molecular diagnostic lab cologne
germany i'm christy jewel of labyrinth
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinths and brought to
you by ge healthcare life sciences to
learn more about our sponsor please
visit gelifesciences.com
now let's get started i would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send we will answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation click on the
support tab found at the top right of
the presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the ask a
question box
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits
i now present today's speaker dr
stephanie stepanov
dr stepanov is an ngs core facility
manager in a private molecular
diagnostic lab in clone germany
she is responsible for the establishment
and validation of new and gs essays as
well as monitoring and optimization of
current ngs workflows
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr stepanov you may now begin your
presentation
oh thank you very much for the nice
introduction um the topic of my talk is
approaches to nucleic acid isolation
from sample to ngs analysis
today i will talk about how to check
quality of liquid biopsy samples and the
potential impact of the quality on data
outcomes
we will review modifications to
workflows protocol steps
and mgs analysis
i would talk about benefits and
drawbacks of different approaches to
nuclear acid isolation with particular
focus on column-based and magnetic
beat-based isolation methods
finally we will review sequencing data
comparing column-based and magnetic
beat-based approaches
in molecular diagnostics we analyze
diagnostically and or therapeutically
relevant markers in a genome or proteome
of a patient
for this
a broad collection of techniques are
available the quantitative real-time pcr
is the standard method in our lab and we
use it for the detection of fusion
events for snipped genotyping
the detection and verification of copy
number variations just to mention a few
applications
pcr and subsequent zener sequencing is
still the gold standard for the
detection of german invariants
fragment length analysis are used for
the fetal anaerobic testing as well as
microsatellite instability etc
target-specific copy number variations
and methylation operations could be
checked through multiplex ligation
dependent probe amplification in mlpa
every cgh is used for genome genome-wise
screaming for chromosomal operations a
very sensitive technique is the digital
droplet pcr
that brings you down to 0.1 detection
limit of a known mutation
next generation sequencing is a
well-established method and we could use
this for screening and also targeted
approaches with a high sensitivity
there are several ngs applications i
only mention some of the standards used
in the clinical routine the
characterization of microbiome
communities becomes more and more
standard analysis in the diagnostic lab
mainly stool and vaginal swab samples
are analyzed
a very special application of the polar
body analysis
which is a single cell analysis this is
the pre-implantation testing of in vitro
fertilized oocyte to reduce abortion
rates during the subsequent pregnancy
furthermore fetal anoploidies could be
analyzed through ngs analysis from the
blood out of the mother
but the most commonly used application
is the targeted resequencing of specific
genetic regions to detect germline
automatic mutations
as you see
you have to handle a lot
of different sample types in a
diagnostic lab and this is only one
section and only some examples of
applications
besides the single cell analysis liquid
biopsy samples used for the detection of
somatic mutations and fetal anubilities
are demanding and i will focus on that
sample type in this talk
what is liquid biopsy it is the sampling
of body fluids like blood urine saliva
and cerebral spinal fluid that to
analyze specific biomarker
circulating tumor cells or ctcs
originate from a primary tumor and may
over the blood circulation constitutes
seeds for
development of additional tumors in
distant organs
ctcs are very rare and difficulty and
rich ctcs are not routinely used in
tumor diagnostics at the
moment the most commonly used biomarker
is cell-free dna and blood samples
selfie dna is a generic term for
cell-free circulating dna in a liquid
biopsy sample
circulating tumor in act dna and
cell-free fetal dna are only a portion
of cell-free dna
two processes are involved in the
release of cell-free dna into blood
circulation
the first
is the passive relief of dna through
cell death either by apoptosis or
necrosis
during apoptosis the nucleosome
associated dna is cleaved by enzymes
resulting in a characteristic cell-free
dna length of around 160
base pairs
dna released from phargocytosis of
necrotic cells is larger about 10
000 base pairs and higher
the second mechanism is by active
secretion secretion of dna takes place
by the release of exosomes or other
extracellular layer with sickles
containing pieces of dna around 150 and
200 base pairs
the amount of cellphone dna is
influenced by several factors like age
thresh
stress or even inflammation but also
cancer cells and the developing fetus
releases dna into bloodstream which is
the cause that we could use liquid
biopsy samples in a diagnostic routine
the first fda approved application of
liquid biopsy was the screening for
fetal anabloidis in maternal blood the
so-called nipt
non-invasive prenatal testing
this method has the advantage that the
collection of plaque of the pregnant
woman is minimally invasive compared to
the more sensitive tissue sampling via
amniocentesis which could lead to an
induced abortion of the fetus
routinely nipt is used to screen for
aberrant chromosomes
13 18 and 21 and defronted sex
chromosomes
also the detection of whole genome
aberrations are possible
the fetal cell free dna fraction
correlates nicely with gestational age
and after the 10th or
the 12th gestational week the cell-free
fetal dna fraction is more than 4
percent which is considered to represent
a threshold for reliable testing
this makes it easy to standardize the
workflow in the routine
liquid
liquid biopsy
analysis and cancer patients are much
more difficult to standardize
the amount of released tumor dna depends
on the tumor entity
disease stage or tumor burden and also
the microenvironment of the tumor
the example
for example the access to blood vessels
etc
as a consequence the circulating tumor
dna could vary a lot between patients
even in the same disease stage
that makes it so difficult to
standardize circulating tumor dna
analysis in a routine lab
but the advantages of liquid biopsy is
the minimal invasive sampling the
accessibility and the possibility to
collect samples at short intervals
furthermore tissue biopsies often do not
reflect the heterogeneity of a tumor
liquid biopsy analysis in cancer
patients could be used for cancer
detection even at early stage and
molecular profiling of the tumor after
surgery the detection of residual
disease could be done by sensitive
approaches like qpcr digital droplet pcr
ngs
during treatment the response could be
monitored as well as the clone evolution
of recurrent tumor cells
to establish the cell free dna analysis
in a routine diagnostic lab the
characteristics of sarcoid in a should
be considered
therefore dna shows low concentration in
plasma as well as our body fluids in
healthy control zephyr dna
concentrations
from 0.3 to 10 nanograms per milliliter
plasma were described
in cancer patient concentrations from
eight to eight hundred nano columns per
milliliter plasma were found
therefore dna has a short fragment
length which is directly
depends on the origin of the dna as i
mentioned before sephie dna released
from apoptotic cells show a mean
fragment size of around
166 base pair 2 to enzymatic cleavage
selfie dna from necrotic cells are often
large over 1000 base pairs
active release selfie dna shows the mean
fragment length around 150 and 200 base
pairs
important is to know that cell free
self-reference in the mean
shorter
than the cell free maternal dna as you
see in the picture
the same characteristic could be found
in cancer patients
where melanoma cell free dna is enriched
in the shorter fragments compared to
healthy donor self redeem aim
the establishment of selfie dna routine
analysis includes some pre-analytical
considerations the choice of blood
collection tube is very important there
are several blood collection tubes for
the sampling of salford dna on the
market these contain nuclear acid and
cell stabilizing additives that prevent
the self-redeem area and white blood
cells from degradation
the usage of plasma versus serum needs
to be considered total cell free dna
levels are 1.6 to 11 fold higher in
serum compared to plasma samples it was
also shown that the isolated cell free
dna integrity is higher in serum
compared to plasma but the measured
allele frequencies in serum were lower
compared to plasma samples
glutanet eye compared theorem versus
plasma and also two different
extraction methods beads and
membrane-based isolation kits i come to
that later in more detail
but you could see on this figure
the measured leaf frequency in serum are
lower compared to plasma samples at
which the experimental detected
frequency from the plasma samples
reflect the expected allele frequencies
the release of cellular dna seems to be
taking place during the blood clotting
process from lysine cells and this
explains the higher yield in integrity
of circulating dna obtained from serum
as a conclusion serum is more unstable
and difficult to control fluid due to
the coagulation process but may be used
if plasma is not available
in addition to blood collection tubes
and specimen type the storage which
means
temperature and duration should be
tested and established in the lab the
storage duration depends on the type of
blood collection tubes you use
when you analyze plasma samples the
generification pro procedure have to be
tested and validated with the local
equipment parameter to test our speed
time temperature and number of spins
all parameter could have an influence on
the fdna yield in quality and needs to
be carefully considered in the clinical
routine
one major factor
that influence yield in quality of
cellphone dna is the choice of the
extraction method
two most commonly used methods are
silica based membrane so-called
column-based
and magnetic beat-based isolation
methods you already mentioned study from
claude net r
compared the membrane-based cayenne-free
circulating nuclear acid kit from kyogen
with the beet-based maxwell rsc
self-redeem dna plasma kit from promega
the figure shows a comparison of
measured selfie dna quantities in
nanogram per microliter isolated with
membrane and bead-based isolation kits
left the quantities of the short
fragments below 600 base pairs are shown
in the right the measured quantities of
the long fragments are compared
as you can see membrane based isolation
promotes extraction of long selfie dna
fragments compared to the beat based
isolation method
on the left figure the percentage
of fragments are compared between the
both isolation methods with particular
interest in short and long fragments the
magnetic beak-based isolation method
recovered more efficiently shorter
fragments of cell-free dna
besides the small differences in
fragment lengths preference differences
in yield and quality of the extraction
methods have to be tested and validated
for the needs of subsequent analysis
steps within the local setting
to establish a quality control for
self-redeem dna samples you have to
consider the selfie dna characteristics
low concentration and short fragments
for quantification of sephora dna you
could use fluorescence-based methods
like cupid or an equivalent technique
please do not use absorption methods
they are not sensitive enough
this fluorescent dye intercalates in
double stranded dna and the procedure is
cost effective rapid and simple
to measure fragment length and a
possible contamination with longer
fragments of white blood cell dna
the by analyzer or fragment analyzer
from agilent are a good choice
both are very sensitive capillary gel
electrophoresis you need only small
amounts of dna
we use both methods to control the
quality of 17 in our lab
some labs use
qpcr instead of qubit and by analyzer
this has the advantage of detection of
portions of amplifier dna in your sample
when you establish a multiplex qpcr
amplifying
different amplicon lengths you could
also get information about integrity of
the sample
besides that a methylation-specific qpcr
could quantify the cell-free fetal
proportion in your sample
what kind of qc measurement you
establish in your lab depends on your
preferences and
your lab equipment important is to not
over measure the sample and save
material
the cell free dna attributes also have
an impact on downstream processes
the short fragment length limits the
amplicon length if you use pcr for
target enrichment
and subsequent ngs analysis or even qpcr
the amplicon must be shorter than 150
base pairs better is around 120 base
pairs or you perform whole genome
sequencing that it is in an ipt analysis
and as i mentioned before
you know mutated elites from cancer
origin are enriched in shorter fragments
a selection for short fragments could
improve the outcome either by
experimental enrichment with a magnetic
beat based extraction method or by a
bioinformatical enrichment of short
fragments
the low concentration is the most
challenging parameter with such limited
material you have not unlimited attempts
to get to the result the analysis
strategy should be based on low amounts
of input dna
i prefer
personally pcr nutrients over
hybridization methods because they are
more specific and you only need low
amounts of dna but it has been shown
that also some hybridization strategies
work on cell free dna
but to achieve a certain sensitivity you
need a certain amount of input dna
20 nanograms of dna correspond to 6600
around
genomes
if your clone has one percent allele
frequency
you have to detect 66 liters in your
analysis also
contamination with white blood cell dna
reduces the chance to get the mutated
alleles
using unique molecular barcodes
so-called human eye
umis could increase the sensitivity by
reducing background sickness
recently we started the establishment of
a selfie dna
ngs analysis workflow in our lab and i
would like to show you the first results
we compared two extraction methods the
column-based isolation kit kayam
circulating nucleic acid kit from
kaio-chan
with the beep-based kidzera extractor
selfie dna isolation kit from ge
healthcare
as a reference we use the hd
817 sample from horizon discovery this
is fragmented dna in a synthetic plasma
matrix
the reference contains
four samples with spiked pathogenic
mutations with four
five percent one percent 0.1 percent and
a y type with zero percent
the ngs library was performed with the
custom multiplex pcr panel which uses
the ampliseq hd technology from flemmer
fischer scientific that technology
provides unique molecular indices
the mean amplicom size of our panel is
around 114 base pairs
the eight libraries we are then
sequenced on year five
the ion torrent technology on a single
ship
the procedure of the comparison is shown
here the one millimeter per sample was
divided into two 0.5 millimeter plasma
samples the isolation was performed
following the respective instruction of
the kits
except the illusion
this was modified to 30 microliters in
low tem
then quality control with cupid and by
analyzer were performed after
normalization of the input dna library
preparation including library quality
control via qpcr was done followed by
subsequent sequencing on es5
the preparation of this alpha dna was
done manually and the duration of the
prep was equal between both kits
the first quality control step was the
quantification of the isolated zephyr
dna
on that figure you see the concentration
in nanogram per microliter of this alpha
dna isolate isolated by a beat based
method compared to the column based
method as you can see there's the five
five-fold higher differences between the
two methods
the blue line
indicated the expected concentration
given by horizon discovery this was
calculated considering dilution volume
of 13 microliters
the dotted line
indicate the maximal concentration given
by the amount of dna used for the
production of the reference plasma
sample
the cell-free dna isolated with the
kayaking kit is above this maximum
therefore an overestimation is suspected
then
the fragment length was checked by by
analyzer and in a high sensitivity assay
for this experiment we verified
the findings in the literature beat
based isolation we cover more
efficiently short fragments
before library preparation we normalize
the dna input to 20 nanograms the
library prep was done in parallel and
library qc was performed using the
respective ion torn qpcr kit
the quantification revealed the
differences between the two extraction
extraction methods the kaiakan cell free
dna showed two times lower final library
concentration than the beat approach
routinely we normalize our ngs ampliseq
hd libraries to 100 picomolar what we
could not do in this experiment
you have to keep that in mind when you
look at the sequencing results the total
read counts reflect this pooling method
we have more reads for the beat based
sample compared to the membrane-based
samples but when you look at the
percentage of q20 bases and the mean
read length there's no difference
between the samples isolated either by
column-based or beat-based approaches
furthermore what is not shown here the
on target reads and the uniformity of
the coverage is very similar and showed
no differences between the two setups
so we could say that the ngs data
quality is comparable between beats and
membrane-based isolation methods
the next and maybe the most important
question is are there differences in the
sensitivity between both isolation
methods
and is our ngs workflow sensitive enough
to detect all mutant elites
the used horizon reference sample
comprised four samples with spike
pathogenic mutations and five percent
one percent and 0.1 percent frequency
and a wild type
you could see the frequency of reads
with the mutant allele and the total
coverage at the position of the
petrogenic mutation g to d at position
12 and key rays
we did not find the 0.1 percentage
mutation in the kyogen prepared samples
this may be due to the lower read
coverage resulting from the lower total
reads
the next mutation we look at
is the amino acid change from e to k at
position
545 and peak
3 ca again we have problems to detect
the 0.1
mutation
independent of the extraction method
obviously our tested workflow is not
robust enough to detect 0.1 mutation
frequencies so we have to adapt the
workflow to get a better sensitivity and
we will start to increase the dna input
in the library preparation
but the depth
to that point we could say that both
extraction methods could show
an equal performance regarding the
sensitivity
to summarize this talk we could say that
cefi dna is a challenging biomarker
because of low concentration and short
fragment length
a lot of variables could influence yield
and quality of self-regen aim therefore
it's important to carefully consider all
variables during the establishment of a
clinical routine
but we could see that magnetic beats
recovers more efficiently short
fragments compared to the membrane-based
method
and both extraction methods
showed comparable ngs data quality and
sequencing results in our lab in the end
i would like to thank my team for
helping me with that establishment and
she healthcare for the opportunity to
test exit before launch
and also to present my data
in this presentation and you for your
attention i'm happy to answer your
question
thank you dr stepanov for that
informative presentation it is now time
for our live q a portion of our webinar
now to our audience if you have not
submitted your question yet please do so
now just click on that ask a question
box located on the far left of your
screen and we will answer as many of
your questions as we have time for okay
let's get started
our first question is let's start with
this one we already have some great
questions coming in
can i use any nucleic acid isolation kit
for set dna extraction
um oh
look at my voice it's um get arrested
for a lot of talking okay
um
while this way work generic nuclear
basic kits are not optimized for sephora
dna extraction so
this is the sensitivity and
the recovery will not be efficient
enough and i think
[Music]
the the output would be
poor
now can i use
any blood vacutainer for storing blood
for safe dna analysis
no
best practice would be to use any blood
collection tube
specific for cell free dna analysis
and
because this is
their additives in it
they preserve the nucleic acid
for degradation and also stabilize blood
cells
to minimize the release of genomic dna
okay
thank you
now how long do you store the blood in
the plasma and under what conditions
this really depends on the kind of
plaque collection tube you use in our
lab we have experience with strike
selfie dna plaque collection tubes which
you could store
about
14 days from 6 to
37 degrees
and biometrica blood collection tubes
which are stabilizing the cellphone dna
for up to seven days
in routine
we centrifuge the blood as soon as
possible
that means within 24 hours and store the
plasma then at minus 80 degrees
thank you
why the 150 bp or lower
um
for the design of the the multiplex
essay
the maximum of the fabri dna is at 166
so to say base pairs
and the smaller one
like
self-refeeded dna or the the
circulating tumor dna is more smaller so
you have to have the chance that you get
a pcr product from it
so i would
recommend to use the multiplex pcr
approach with 120 base pairs but it
works also with 150 or also 170 base
pairs
thank you
can you explain the difference in
estimation of cef dna concentration
over a overestimation of qi amp and
absence of difference in sensitivity
[Music]
the overestimation coming from the
kayaking kit i would explain
by the usage of
carrier trna used in the kyogen workflow
this is a double-stranded
on a and the die of the cubit may
intercalate to the double-stranded
portions
so this is why it's maybe overestimated
and
we are not
finished with our establishing process
or validation process so
i could not really say why
the there's no differences or there's no
difference in sensitivity i would say um
this is
this 0.1 percent is
very low concentration and this is the
advertised detection limit of that essay
we used
and we used therefore 20 nanogram
input dna input
and which is around
6600 hypogenome copies and
1.0.1 percent means that you have to
find and sequence six to seven alleles
and
um
i think we have to to increase the dna
and then we could say something about
the sensitivity of that essay
thank you we've got some great questions
coming in let's go with this next
question
um what problem
can we have if we choose more than 150
bp for example 200 or 300 bp
when you choose um
larger or longer amplicons you may be
getting bias in your output
so cell free dna
it's preferably shorter fragments so
i think you missed some
you missed the sequence in your analysis
then
we've seen it we've done um
multiplex fragment length analysis and
we missed the longer fragments in our
in our outcome
thank you
now while using emphasis for sequencing
do you think that the error rate would
have improved by using a different
sequencing platform such as illumina
we know about the differences we have
both platforms in our lab so the iron
torn platforms have
high
reproducible error rates in homopolymer
regions
and the illumina error rates
they are more
by accident so
with this reproducible error rates
we could um analyze reference dna
from but we know that there are
certain mutations
at certain positions and then we could
normalize or
train our
bioinformatic pipeline
for the illumina this sequencing is
better than compared to the iron torrent
analysis but the just not systematic
errors
[Music]
are difficult to
to define as
artifacts because we are going down to a
really low level frequency so
0.1 percent is really challenging to use
it but there are also some
techniques using human eyes
with illumina sequencing so in our lab
we have both platforms for the for this
we use iron torrent
excellent thank you
what is the cause of the overestimation
of step dna extracted with the kyogen
kit
oh as i mentioned um some questions
before i think this is the the usage of
the
carrier trna
but i'm
i'm not sure i've asked
the qubit
[Music]
support
and they couldn't answer me this
question
so this is just i suspect the carrier on
a
thank you now we have an attendee asking
i missed how much set dna was present in
the horizon controls
um this is written on the horizon
discovery information sheet
i'm not sure i said
maximum
i have to look it up
sorry or you will find it
specification sheet for that hd
817 sample
okay thank you
is extraction efficiency the same with
various set dna stabilization tubes
we tested only strech and biometric plat
collection tubes in our lab and we find
the same results
but this is one you have to test
this is one to be considered and to be
tested in your lab settings
thank you now we have so many great
questions coming in and i want to make
sure we try to fit them all in but if uh
we are unable to answer some of these
questions due to time constraints i want
to remind our audience that these
questions will be answered via email to
the contact information that you
provided at the time of registration so
let's keep going our next question can
you detect mutations that are localized
near the end of a dna fragment
especially the short short ones for
example less than 70 bp
i'm not sure if i get the question so if
you have this
pcr amplicon sequencing
it is
the detection does not
it's not related or does not depend on
the position in the amplicon
because um
it's not like in sangha sequencing where
you have uh get the signal um
over the noise
um
i'm not sure if that was answering the
question
but this um
we could all localize all mutations
in the whole amplicon
okay our next question
what are the risks of using more than
170 bp
to miss the information
okay
do you think enrichment of specific
self-dna fragments that contain
mutations of interest would increase
sensitivity of ngs
[Music]
some paper shows some studies showed
that
the enrichment of short cell free dna
fragments could increase the sensitivity
of ngs
so
[Music]
as i mentioned it
could be done by the usage of maybe a
extraction method which efficiently
recover more short fragments
or bioinformatical i know for the nipt
workflow that
this is done
though does it that they enrich the the
short fragments and
increase their sensitivity
thank you now our next question
i already use a column-based kit in our
lab why change to mag bead-based kit for
sas dna isolation
when it's working you don't have to
change
in our lab we decided to change because
of automation we would like to
have an automotive
workflow in our lab
and also
the enrichment of shorter fragments
could be an advantage and we
don't want to use this centrifuge or
vacuum methods in our lab anymore but
the main reason is the automation
[Music]
thank you is your method automatable
um
both kits um i used in this um
comparison uh the kayaking kit is
somehow semi-automatical
so it's done with this vacuum container
and then it could be
enriched
or isolated using the the kayaku
and the the
server extractor beads this is fully
automatable
thank you okay let's see we have so many
great questions coming in uh let's
try let's go with this one
do you think stabilization chemistry
such as cross-linking
use of formaldehyde
impact extraction efficiency
or workflow
yeah it's like ffpe it's also from form
altitude cross-linking and it's
having great influence on the subsequent
ngs analysis
sorry um yeah
thank you um here's a great question
what kind of extraction method do you
prefer
both kids have their benefits and
drawbacks and as i said in our lab
we would like to we prefer an automatic
solution because we have a lot of
or many liquid biopsy samples
but the point is whatever extraction
method you use you have to carefully
establish and validate the workflow
under the conditions in your lab
thank you now we have time for a few
more questions
have you tested different analysis
techniques on chef dna extracted with
the mentioned kit
yes we have also tested digital droplet
pcr and the nipt workflow
and we found all aberrations and
mutations with both methods so the
results are highly comparable
thank you
uh let's go with this next question
i think we can fit in
two more um how can isolated stuff dna
be quantified
okay i showed you that um
you could quantify it
with a flowmetric method like cubit
and then also look at the fragment
length with the bioanalyzer or the
fragment analyzer
or some labs have
qpcr established but you can also
quantify
the selfridge in a using
digital droplet pcr ngs by counting the
alleles two more mutual mutated alleles
thank you and we have time for one last
question and we'll wrap with this one
does ge have other kits that i can use
for my sequencing workflow
yes i think so um
ge is more and more becoming a solution
provider for the ngs market and
they are planning
to launch a series of kits to complement
the ngs portfolio and i know about the
ffpe kit which i'm also interested in
also they have pcr and
qpcr
solutions
and i will i think they also have a
library prep site selection and cleanup
kit yes of course they have some
magnetic beats for library and um
cleanup pcr cleanup
thank you
now i do want to thank you again dr
stephanie spana for your time today and
your important research i'd also like to
thank lab roots and our sponsor ge
healthcare life sciences for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i want to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions there were
quite a few questions we were unable to
answer so those questions we were not
able to answer and those that are
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by dr stephanos via
the email address you provided at the
time of registration thanks for joining
us and we hope to see you again soon
have a great day
you